[Applaudissements]
merci pour le lancement c'est un saint
on en parlait tout à l'heure ça va
animer à sers de ma fille demain et j'ai
pris un petit un petit cahier de
coloriage
elle va avoir 9 en dollars c'est un
grand poids regardez il ya un spécial
c'est un cahier de coloriage donc savez
comme ça voilà up assez à oui c'est très
dommage c'est tout ça comment avec des
collants il ya quelques années c'est pas
moi qui le colorier sauf que comme j'ai
des pouvoirs magiques
il suffit juste de souffler une personne
à langnau sans eau ni à comprendre votre
assistante attitré fait différent
c'était votre assistant tout à l'heure
c'était délicat les textes sont il
suffit qu'elle souffle un petit peu et
je vais faire disparaître le corps les
avants ont soufflé voilà au pas trop
fort worth était intense participer le
public
les dessins sont le coloriage
si vous pouvez souffler là bas pas vous
finalement autonome vous soufflez pas
possible tough on y va magnifique merci
merci merci merci
on y va et
[Applaudissements]
en suisse et pas de vivre c'est un peu
comme votre tour avec le jean michel
nous a beaucoup impressionné tout à
l'heure j'ai trouvé un cahier de travail
de jean-michel leurs coupons les notes
pour l'émission merde voilà y'a pas
besoin de souffler on va voir son cahier
voilà ça c'est quelqu'un d'autre pour
l'émission sur plusieurs années un jeu
que se concentre lui aussi voilà on l'a
pas vu à la caméra est ce qu'on appelait
la caméra toutes les notes depuis que
jean michel et dans l'émission qui
l'attend sur l'émission accès à ses
rangs top il a un pouvoir extraordinaire
je vais faire appel à son pouvoir
sensitifs et tel un mentaliste
nous allons pouvoir lire ce qu'il ya
dans sa tête ou là là là là là non
oui on s'en sort mieux que ce que tu
souhaites tu révèles est-ce que c'est
faux que les hanter la mention n'y voit
rien
[Applaudissements]
il ya vraiment des mathématiques
non
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]